well it's finally happened Donald
Trump's own lawyer is now defending
Trump not by saying there was no
collusion with Russia but by saying
collusion isn't a crime I'm talking of
course of Donald Trump's star attorney I
guess
Rudy Giuliani who was on CNN and Fox
News and he said it he's just not sure
collusion is a crime and for more than a
year now the goal posts have been moving
on right-wing media about Trump Russia
collusion it started as there won't be
an investigation okay well there's an
investigation but it's not going to find
any collusion well there might be
collusion but collusion wouldn't be a
crime we heard it in the media we heard
it from Steve Doocy or whoever else a
year ago on Fox News but this is a first
step in Trump's own lawyers starting to
take this approach check it out Rudi on
CNN I guess this is now the official
position which is that collusion would
not be a crime he was on multiple
channels yesterday first on Fox and
Friends check it out laughter Rudy
Giuliani president Trump's attorney
former New York City Mayor I've been
sitting here looking in the federal code
trying to find collusion as a crime it's
not collusion is not a crime everything
that's been released so far shows the
president to be absolutely and I've seen
do anything wrong the last two tapes are
evidence in his favor I mean so there it
is on Fox and Friends collusion is not a
crime continuing this narrative now on
CNN and remember this is the president's
lawyer saying not that there was no
collusion but that collusion is not a
crime and we'll talk about the merits of
that in a second but again this is not
just an offhanded statement also saying
it on CNN yesterday but he really wasn't
jarred and and the suns and bossy and
these other people were really running
it so much but okay so what Paul is a
visitor saying that Paul Manfred did not
have any power in the campaign I'm just
saying that said he had a very discrete
important area what I'm saying is he was
never involved an intimate business
relationship with Donald Trump that's
just four months they're not gonna be
polluting about Russians and which I'm
not even know if that's a crime
colluding about Russians okay you start
you start analyzing the crime the
hacking is the crime that's the original
the present-day back course not that's
the originator bag
and as you know it has led the meeting
with the Russian if you've got the
hacked information from the Russians
here at CNN and you played it would you
be in jeopardy of going to jail okay so
of course this is another one of these
semantic games breaking news collusion
collusion not being a crime just isn't
relevant it's like saying drinking and
driving isn't a crime I looked up and
down the entire criminal code I don't
see drinking and driving mentioned
you've got to let me go officer
well no it's called driving under the
influence stealing stealing isn't a
crime in the criminal code bye-bye
police well the crime is called theft
colluding with a foreign power to win an
election and this entire Trump Fiasco so
far could include the crimes of
conspiracy obstruction of justice
receiving things of value from a foreign
power campaign finance violations
witness tampering it's a very very long
list this isn't a relevant conversation
but it is huge in that now it seems to
be the approach of trumps own lawyer to
say that collusion is not a crime as
opposed to there was no collusion and
just hours before this Donald Trump was
still tweeting that there was no
collusion saying quote there is no
collusion the Robert Muller rig
witch-hunt headed now by 17 increase
from 13 including an Obama White House
lawyer angry Democrats were started by a
fraudulent dossier paid for by crooked
Hillary and the DNC
therefore the witch-hunt is an illegal
scam Trump saying there is no collusion
and hours later his own lawyer merely
saying collusion is not a crime how soon
will it be okay
there was no collusion and collusion
would be a crime but you can't charge
the president with crimes because that
would be the next step in this goalposts
moving slide and this is a classic
autocratic authoritarian move Gary
Kasparov tweeted about this a few days
ago saying yes it's the autocratic
method as soon as it's no longer
profitable to deny a crime boast about
it never apologize or show regret
because for a strongman that shows
weakness going on to say as predicted
soon they'll move to boasting how clever
they were to obtain Putin's
makes me smart not a criminal is rudy
giuliani
a terrible lawyer or is this a
brilliantly orchestrated propaganda
technique a calculated propaganda
technique specifically for trump's base
to sow confusion and create skepticism
of media in the style of the world brave
new world as depicted by Aldous Huxley I
don't know the answer either Rudy
Giuliani is the worst lawyer you could
possibly have or he's actually playing
eight-dimensional underwater in the dark
chess I don't know exactly which one it
is I guess we'll find out hopefully
within the next few months